SPEAKER: Android
Studio 3.1 is now
available for download or
update in the Stable channel,
along with version 3.1 of the
Android plugin for Gradle.
With it, we've switched to
using our brand new dexer, D8,
for all your builds.
It produces, on average, 10% to
15% smaller and more optimized
dex bytecode without
requiring any changes
in application code.
D8 also offers faster
dexing, now works
for incremental
builds with the Sugar,
and even provides a better
debugging experience
when stepping through code.
One thing to remember--
if you had previously
disabled the experimental
version of D8 in your project
by setting the Android
enabled D8 flag to false,
it's time to remove this
from Gradle properties.
The sugaring of Java
8 language features
is still done in a separate
step in this release.
However, you can try the
experimental integrated desugar
by setting the enable D8
desugaring flag to true.
The core IDE is now updated with
improvements from IntelliJ Idea
up to the 2017.3 release, which
includes better control flow
analysis for collections and
strings, improved nullability
inference, new quick
fixes, and more.
We also simplified the
build output window.
When you trigger
a sync or build,
we now show a task tree
with execution times
and toggle an error window
in case of a failure.
You can switch between the tree
view and a textural log here.
On the Kotlin front,
Android Studio
3.1 now bundles
the latest plugin
and supports running lint checks
for Kotlin code on the command
line.
We plan to continue
our work to make
sure we're providing first
class support for Kotlin
in our developer tools.
We received a lot of feature
requests for the Android
profilers that were released
in the last version of Studio.
I'm happy to say that,
based on your feedback,
we've added native CPU profiling
for C++ code and the network
profiler can now show request
data and has a threads
timeline.
And to make it easier to find
the information you need,
the CPU and memory profilers
now offer filtering
by class or method name.
If you're using the
layout inspector,
it's now possible to use
reference image overlays
and isolate subtrees
from the view hierarchy.
The layer editor also got some
UX polish with new keyboard
shortcuts, a way to quickly
launch documentation,
and a new command that lets you
convert a view to another type.
And just like we've developed
Android Studios Layout
Editor in step with the
constraint layout library,
in this release, we've
taken additional care
to make the Code
Editor work great when
you're using Room databases.
You will now get SQL code
completion and common actions
such as renaming
and find usages work
across SQL and Java
or Kotlin code.
The Android Emulator
received a lot
of updates since the
last Studio release,
focusing on speed and stability.
We offer the latest
system images
for API levels 26 and 27, which
passed CDS tests and include
the full Play Store.
On the features
side, the largest
and my favorite
improvement is Quick Boot,
which allows you to
resume a saved emulator
session in under six seconds.
It's completely automatic.
After the first boot, whenever
you close the emulator,
a snapshot is saved and used
for subsequent launches.
But in case you
want more control,
you can change snapshotting
behavior in the settings
and even initiate a state
save at any given moment.
Please update to Android
Studio 3.1 and give it a spin.
And if you're
feeling adventurous,
I'd also like to point out
that you can try our early 3.2
Canaries.
As always, we'd love to get your
feedback on the bug tracker.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]